my business is just if what if a door i
say if a door shuts in your face
you just got to kick it open you know
that's kind of hard in my business and
that's the same in property right
you know yeah declined from mortgages
think
things happening going wrong and you
just need to just keep going and you
need to be relentless that's part of
being a part of being an entrepreneur
so yeah we we had an event in london we
had um
500 people booked on it was all fine and
then london went into tier 4
so then we moved it to slow but we
didn't announce it
because we thought slow could and then
salad did
and we were like yes thank god we didn't
announce it and then we announced
southampton
and then the day prior to the event then
southampton council said no
so it was just it was crazy but it's
it's it's all fun
wow i think i think to be honest with
you with everything at the moment
everything's up in the air so
people are having to move adjust uh and
and you know just just see how it goes
you know you've just got to you're
actually right
you've just got to carry on i mean from
our own from our own perspective at the
moment
um obviously we've never spoken before
but we've
from our from our business side of
things it is so chop in turn because
you've got
lenders that are all over the place at
the moment you've got solicitors and the
legal
professional they're all over the place
because all these stand duty holidays
there's so much pressure and um down
valuations are happening there's all
sorts of problems within the
club within the chain um i had a down
valuation today so we had a down
valuation by 70
000 pounds on a property it was a
property in london
so it was a it was a huge so that
basically knocks on the chain
and then other people can't buy and if
it's a residential deal it just
it's an absolute nightmare um so
the the property market i don't know i
mean obviously you you deal with a lot
of people that are investing in
properties and getting in and getting
out
but at the moment what you've what
you've seen is and i've got some lenders
at the moment that are behind by
30 40 days so if you send so you say you
find the property today
and you say prime i'm all good to go my
my offer's been accepted can we put the
application in
in theory that application with some
lenders is going to be looked at
in 40 days time yeah no that's that's
just not acceptable
um i mean exactly and then
and then what you've got is you've got
that process so that
whatever the mortgage application
depending on the lender and so forth and
then once the case gets offered
so the clients are chopping up the bits
saying right we're ready you know we've
got our offer now thank you
and then the solicitors you know the
local authority searchers and the
solicitors are
you know they've got backlogs of
hundreds and thousands of cases right
now
so it'll be in it'll be interesting
actually i want to get your view on
what do you think the stand stamp
holiday stamp duty holiday what do you
think about that do you think
they're gonna extend it or do you think
it will it you know the government's
just gonna cut it off
where it is yeah well last time i
checked a few hours ago i think there's
now
28 000 um
28 000 signatures trying to extend it
from jonathan steele's campaign um
do i think they're going to extend it i
guess it depends on
partly like they have to extend like for
instance furlough
they extended furlough because we
continued being in lockdown so they felt
like they had no choice
so i think it depends on how how the how
the restrictions within lockdown and
everything are i think if we're still
locked down
and they're when they're worried that
the housing market is gonna is gonna dry
up
they're clearly desperate to continue um
you know
continue keeping the economy within the
housing sector going so i think that
they probably will extend it if the kobe
situation doesn't get any better
although i was very surprised
to hear yesterday um i heard that wales
have um you know actually up stamped
duty by one percent which i think was
just an
insane decision so you just you just
can't predict i mean i do make
predictions on youtube and i say i think
you know
i make predictions and often i am right
but sometimes you just cannot
um you know you just cannot predict what
what on earth they're going to do
because
that's yeah
now i i think i think they'll have to
extend it
we've had a couple of government
ministers um sort of come out and say we
we don't have any plans for extension
okay but i think um you've got
you've got the council of mortgage
lenders sort of pushing and saying
look you need to do something about this
there's going to be a bottleneck there's
going to be an issue
you've obviously got the solicitor side
of things the law society side of things
those guys are
sort of making their voices heard saying
look this is going to be a problem you
know there's going to be complaints
there's
potentially i mean you've got zupla that
came out and said
uh around 50 of the people that are
looking to buy in january may lose out
on the stand duty holiday because of all
the backlogs so
it will be i think there would be
madness for them not to extend it but
you never know with this stuff
um but i i do believe if they are going
to extend it they probably will not come
out and tell us this right now because
what will
happen is as soon as you extend it um a
lot of deals are going to fall out of
well out of the deal because a lot of
people have been pushing to buy
before the holiday so they'll just put
the brakes on so i think the government
may
hold out and come out with the news a
little bit closer
to the deadline and about a year ago i
saw your stuff and i was certainly
influenced by a lot of a lot of people
actually
um and i started setting up a youtube
channel and it's just hit
3 000 subscribers congratulations oh
yeah i mean you got to start somewhere
and i think you're right you've got to
be consistent i think with a lot of this
stuff and
obviously i see your stuff and you're
very consistent i mean almost on a daily
basis religiously
you're you're putting out the message
there so um and at first you know i'm a
bit i was a bit dubious to be fair
i saw your stuff and i wasn't quite sure
and i was like i don't know this guy i
don't know what he's talking about
i was thinking to other people and you
know you
the more you watch the more you learn
and
you know the more you observe about
other people so um i was really i was
really
uh glad um because you've got such a
large present
in the in the on you on the web
basically you've got a 180 000
subscribers in one of your channels and
you've got such a big open forum and i
was really pleased that you did take out
the time to actually give me a little
bit of time you know
that shows the character that you have
got that you know you that half seven in
the evening
you're willing to have this discussion
so i really appreciate it yeah no
sure you know it's always good to um you
know to collaborate
and to see what other people are doing
and you know i saw your channel and i
can see that you were a professional
and and know what you're talking about
um so no it's it's
it's a pleasure and you know i put out i
put out a video every single day
uh i've been doing so for oh geez a long
time now i started my youtube channel
about four or five years ago
um bought my first property just after
the crash 2009 i bought my first house
and um kind of just snowballed
snowballed from there
so i've been um you know i've been
buying properties
quite quite aggressively really for the
last sort of 10 11
12 years um set up my training company
in 2016 and that
that really took off i think um you know
i
i just think that i mean my training
programs that i run i quite
like i don't i don't have powerpoint
presentations or anything it's literally
i just go
i get my computer up and i just say
someone give me an area
and someone will give me and then i'll
go right i'm gonna try and find a deal
from scratch in that area
i'll call the agent i'll stack the deal
i'll put a power team together
on the spot live i'm not saying i'm
gonna do the best i'm not saying it's
gonna be perfect
but i want to show you the system so i
just that's that's kind of how i run it
and then i
i do it live and then i get them to do
it
you know and it's very kind of like
practical so
not everybody likes me i've got i've got
my mother
you're always going to be you're always
going to be a target of you know
whatever you we're on the web you put
yourself out there and you're always
going to get
i mean i've seen some of your stuff that
you know you've had
bus stops with various people but at the
end of the day
um you've got you've got negative
energy everywhere you know everyone will
get it but what i would say
is um you know there's no doubt whatever
you can say there's no doubt that you
have um
certainly brought property to a lot of
people that wouldn't necessarily have
got into it
you can't say you're the best i can't
say i'm the best broker out there okay
i'm certainly not
okay but what i would say and and what i
would say is you
all you can do is try to do your best
and try to be
um as information as honest as you can
and there will be some people that will
embrace that and like and there'll be
other people that will say no you know
that's not it's not your thing
and i suppose but what i will say is
there's 180 000 people obviously
who have said yeah actually we want to
listen to this guy a little bit
no yeah you know i get um i i've got a
lot of followers
and um and i think you know i document
pretty much everything i do as well so
when i'm when i'm
investing in a property i'll document it
um start to finish and show people what
i'm doing so i've recently
you know just built six houses from
scratch um
which i documented i've got my castle
that i bought a couple of years ago
which i'm renovating which i'm
documenting
yeah i saw that there's lots of nice
surprises i saw your video on that one
japanese knotweed and bits and pieces oh
yeah it's a wreck
yeah but you know you get that you get
that all the time you know
but it's yeah i've been watching i've
been watching your videos and um
yeah it's interesting the ups and downs
of being a property you know it's not
all
you know it's not all you know
millionaire stuff and you know i made
100k on this one 200k
sometimes you take losses and that's the
way that's the way it is
absolutely i mean to be honest with you
um uh
where do you i mean right now we're in a
bit of a funny place obviously your
training program i saw that you put it
online
and that's working um one thing i will
say samuel that i was really
uh it's quite refreshing right i joined
just
about a month ago not long ago i i
joined your facebook group
okay so i found you and what's quite
good is you have a lot of people there
whether they're new whether they're
experienced
whether they're professionals who are
trying to get business there's different
sort of walks of life in that group but
what i was quite
um impressed with was the amount of
knowledge people are sharing within that
community
so it's a little community and it's it's
not
you know hard sell community it's almost
like someone will come and say i've got
a deal here
what do you think guys and someone would
say well you should get an electrician
to look at
you know it's quite nice for that and
that's and that's a very
and i don't think you talk about that
enough in regards to the community that
you've got there within that facebook
uh environment i thought it was very
very good yeah yeah thanks man i
appreciate that yeah no we've got a
massive
you know really nice community on
facebook on instagram
we've got our paid membership site which
is really busy and
and and and that's really good and i
think that i mean one of the things that
i
i think i'm i'm quite passionate about
in this industry is that i mean watching
your channel you're very much about
the um you know the facts and the
numbers and the figures and the details
your that's your background
uh yeah one of the things that i think i
bring i bring to the table in the
community is the fact that i believe the
property
is is a people business and i you know
and i say this a lot and it used to
really
um it used to really confuse me when i
was starting out in property and people
landlords would say you know oh bloody
tenants or you know i'm allergic to
tenants i'm thinking well
they're the people that are bringing
your income in so you know the way the
way i see things
is that you know your your tenants are
your customers
and your your house is your product and
if you're if you're packaging and
selling deals
you're getting money from investors in
fact
property doesn't actually give anyone
any money it's actually the people
the people property is a vehicle
probably such a massive diverse
um topic with you know
yes you need to be good with numbers but
you also need to be good with people
um if you want if you want to really fly
so
our training programs we teach people
about the numbers and how to
crunch your numbers and work out all
your due diligence but also i think it's
a
it's mindset it's it's about um
taking action it's about implementing
what you learn it's about being able to
deal with people communicate
problem solve so there's a lot to it to
becoming
uh successful in property which um you
know is what i
show people and teach and um i get
results
you know i get results and the reason
i'm able to grow
is because i hardly advertise but it's
because my students just
keep coming through and every week i
have winners on a wednesday i'll
interview people and
you know so it's just for me it's really
fun and i really like it and it's put me
it's giving me a lot of opportunities to
work with great people
um you know so i i really
i really enjoy doing what i'm doing and
um
yeah as i say i'm not my favorite i had
a tough year this year because i had a
lot of i had a lot of bad press
the reality is everyone's had a tough
year and
uh our business okay so you would have
thought we've been very busy for the
last couple of months okay
fantastic really good however we
pre-couple of months ago
because of the brexit situation and
because of the uncertainty
the market was it was really up and down
so when you look at us
and you think okay well we've had a very
decent sort of towards the back of the
year because of all the tax changes
but the beginning of the year was an
absolute nightmare for us because
of all the changes so and every business
is going through it we were lucky enough
we've been lucky because
we could work remotely um our business
hasn't been affected too much because
we haven't been to the office for
example the office that we've got we
haven't been to the office since
you know march yeah
as a property investor it doesn't help
with the speed
of things when you're trying to get
things over the line fast because you'll
be like oh everyone's working from home
you can't just go into the office it
does it does
it it does slow things down i mean it's
been great for us in some regards
because
i mean i mean commercial one of the
reasons commercial properties
are dropping in value is because of that
exact reason because people aren't
renting offices anymore so um commercial
commercial properties
a drop in um but yeah it's a really
interesting yeah
i don't think we'll ever go back to the
same as it was i think that unless
you're
unless you're adapting and pivoting a
lot and i know there's a really overused
word at the moment but
it's it's it's really really true i mean
we were
we had 43 people uh in an office
central london in marleybone um you know
i was going back and forth from i live
in beckham's field i was going back and
forth tomorrow been on the train every
day
we had a little nice little setup and um
just now it's just changed i don't think
we'll ever go back to what we had i
think it will be better
and and but just different um
so it's been a it's been a yeah very
very interesting year but
some people are so freaking out because
i keep seeing to push back the lockdown
my attitude is i didn't live through it
but if we can get through world war one
and world war ii we can definitely get
through this this current its current
crisis
no it'll definitely we definitely will
get through it but it's just it's
it'll be interesting to see how
everything changes for example you
mentioned on commercial
obviously with all the promoted
development changes okay that's an
area where property investors are
potentially looking at to get value real
value
i've certainly seen a lot more now what
i would say is niche advice we're
a traditional mortgage broker we
typically have
only really over the last few years well
we've only really dealt with the more
residential and buy-to-let and portfolio
landlord stuff
obviously we do the bridging stuff but
we've been doing more and more
commercially sort of minded
deals now so whether it's full-blown
commercial deals
development stuff ground-up development
but also we're now getting a lot more
conversion stuff so buying a shop um two
flats on top
whether they're going to keep the shop
or now more and more
it's converting to converting the whole
thing so
the two residentials will stay as it is
converting the flat downstairs into a
residential property so
i'm seeing a lot more of that going on
because as people start looking for
value
the difficulty with that is um a lot of
those type of deals
where they fall through is
because the commercial element has got
other commercial elements on the road
so although you can get the planning
permission the lending is very difficult
so to actually
lend on those if it's a let's just say
it's a block okay
and it's got a shop next door to it but
it's it's you know you've converted that
into a residential property now you've
got your bridging finance so you're all
fine
you probably get it on bridging but to
get that exited out on a residential
billet deal or residential residential
home
is very hard because the lenders will
not do it because everything's too soon
right now
and all the traditional lenders will say
there's too many commercials around it
there's a pub opposite it or there's a
restaurant next door to it
and they're not they're turning those
type of deals down so
it'll be interesting to see if the the
lenders will evolve
with their views oh because i think i
think they will i think there's
at the moment there's so much change
that's going on and lenders
are um wary aren't they they're just a
bit unsure about what's happening
and when they're wary then they're more
restricted as to what they'll do and
what they'll and what they'll
agree on and how much they'll lend i
mean ultimately i mean the
permitted development changes are i i do
definitely think that the government i
don't know if you saw did you see the
government announcement on the 16th of
december where they said that they're
going to be putting 100
100 million um funding towards
helping developers and house builders
with brown brownfield sites
um it's just a it's a it's quite big you
should definitely check it out
is that job for me so is that actual
genuine sort of you know your smaller
guys
getting that help i think that's the
that will be the fundamental
the thing is though even if it's helping
the big guys and not the small guys is
that what is that what you said
yeah my thoughts my thoughts are there's
only so much
so we're searching for land constantly
to develop on there's only so much land
available
if if the big boys are snatching
everything up at the moment if
the government give a hundred million to
help turn brownfield
sites and it helps development even if
it helps the big boys that's fine
let them let them take all those big
brownfield sites
and then at least it frees up more um
you know if it gives more land
um it's going to help i think it will
help everybody that's in the development
space and i can definitely see that the
government are
making a massive effort to help
developers yeah they're trying to the
reality is the government
really doesn't want your one or two
buy-to-let landlords no
no no they don't want so they're trying
through taxation and through various
rules they're trying to weed that sort
of stock out
but unfortunately it's had an opposite
effect because what you've had
is you've got the stamp duty holiday
which can be used so
what i'm seeing a lot of is applicants
keeping their flat want to buy a house
but they'll keep that flat
okay or keep that property there in
they'll keep it as a buy to let they'll
convert that into a buy to let and then
buy another one
so what you are having with with these
taxation change or
better yet i'm doing a lot more where
this they're selling their existing
property to a limited
company and then going residential
property
okay that stock is being kept rather
than
being sold off now what's gonna i think
what's gonna probably affect all of this
is if the government comes in and makes
tweaks to the capital gains tax
because then your average one or two man
landlord who was just i'm just going to
keep that property i think then they
potentially have to think about it
either they have to scale up and become
you know three four five six seven buy
tillets
or they may just say you know what it
might be too much we might have to get
rid of it
so it'll be interesting but it's there's
no doubt in my mind the government
really doesn't really like
you know under two or three sort of
vitality they don't like it they want
people to go into a limited comp well
i'm gonna say they want people to go
into limited company but i would say
they would want
more of the portfolio professional
landlords yeah but when they're talking
about capital gains tax it could be a
little bit of scaremongering just to try
and get people to sell
because they want people to sell their
properties right now
so you never know you never know what
the what the agenda is
um you know there's so much nonsense
going around in the newspapers and
it's just it's so transparent i mean i
can see
right through a lot of it there was um
some some agents some estate agents in
liverpool and i was
talking talking about how you know sell
your houses now there's about to be a
big crash quick
everyone sell your house now and it's
like no
the liverpool estate agents want more
stock
because when they get a house it sells
like that and they just need more stock
so they're feeding a [ __ ] story to
the newspapers
because they want more stock the
newspapers are just buying it and it's
just a nonsense story yeah house prices
are not about to crash in liverpool i
mean
it's possible but i just i just can't
see it for a minute so i just think
are they are they going to double
capital gains tax well you know what i
don't even care because i'm not planning
on buying and selling
i'll just refinance anyway i'm not
really cheap i'm not really too
concerned
um about the capital gains tax my
strategy is to not
you know buy and buy and sell well one
thing for sure one thing's for sure even
looking back at the last crash because i
was in the middle of it we worked in a
mortgage company i mean it was like it
was
absolutely i mean in 2007 i think that
mortgage company this company called
mortgage fund did
seven billion in mortgages yeah okay so
we were responsible seven billion of
transaction
so it was a large entity and i know what
it was like but what i will say is
in the last crash gordon brown was the
chancellor just came out pretty much
blatantly and said
i'm not going to let the housing market
go so i will do whatever it takes
but i'm going to let i'm not going to
let the housing market go pop
okay and to be fair to them they didn't
um and that's why you had a lot of
people that did the self-certification
mortgages
that were getting the interest only sell
mortgages but they actually did really
well out of it
because they were buying 10 15
properties
and those properties now 20 years later
or 15 years later
have actually gone immensely hugely up
in value
so they did actually really well out of
it okay of the last crash
and i just think um you've got to take
it with a pinch of salt because
the government people forget and i saw a
video on
i think we're coming around the same way
on this the government has got
some skin in the game the government is
responsible for help dubai
so they've got hundreds of thousands of
people who they have
backed financially yeah to
be able to purchase a home but also
they've got some skin in the game to
keep those homes
okay so you've got all of these you've
got three four hundred thousand people
that are on health dubai
that essentially couldn't buy the
property themselves
so the government who had to come in
with some sort of loan agreement
in terms of backing the lenders so if
the property prices are going to go down
or a crash as such all of those people
are going to be sort of looking at the
government too yes
so i i i actually i actually believe
that
whatever happens the the uk economy
their government whether they can or
they can't
they will do their best to try to
support the housing market
and we've seen that with the tax changes
yeah have you seen my
controversial videos on help to buy i
don't like them i've never
i've been and i i saw one of yours and
you just
basically said um you did you didn't
like to help the white
concept as a yeah i did i did like an
eight-minute video absolutely
ripping into the help to buy skin um and
it got some of my videos have been
removed
like literally youtubers removed them
no they have to buy one it's interesting
because i have got clients
i do have to buy okay i've got clients
that generally help the buyers help them
because they're on good salaries really
big salaries however they just don't
have the deposit i'll give you an
example perfect example is
a lot of foreign national i.t
consultants and people like that that
have got really good well-paying jobs
okay uh or i.t consultants here they've
got well-paid but they just don't have
the deposits to buy in london
that works in in a in a way okay
i'm not a big fan of health by flats at
all new build flats i'm not a big fan of
in regards to health device
but it's held some so i did a video and
some of my friends and some of the
comments underneath it is like
it's rich of you saying why don't you
you know don't go and buy a property
you sit in your own house and you're
telling us not to go and buy a property
i'm saying i'm not about that it's i
just don't like the concept of it
yeah i mean what what what i'd say is
because help to buy usually means you
have to buy
a new build property and yeah i mean i
sell your bills
i sell new build properties and i know
how it works and as soon as you buy it
it loses value
it loses value so to buy a new build
and to become highly leveraged on a
brand new build which is a liability
because it's not making you any money
because you've got to live in it
it's riddled with risk and listen i'm
not saying it's um
you know it's it's never a good idea for
anyone to ever do it
but just have your eyes open and be
careful you know that's basically
it's got development and development
what type of block what type of area
but you're absolutely right because the
developers essentially know
that the client is going to get a 20 or
40 percent
loan and it is a loan it's not a grant
it's a load yeah
what are they doing they've just bumped
their prices yeah yeah exactly
and that's why i say i call it help to
sell it's help to sell skin
you know yes absolutely it's great for
me
the share prices so when you if you look
at the share prices of some of the
biggest house builders
where they were before help them and
where they are now
it just paints its own picture really
yeah um
but now that's that's useful i i think
we're coming from the same
angle on that one how are you finding um
at the moment obviously you deal with a
lot of newly
sort of people coming into the property
market yeah okay
um i would say that samuel i would say
one thing for all those people that come
to your courses there's probably
a hundred that don't or a thousand that
don't and unfortunately what happens a
lot of those
guys end up phoning people like me
they've got no experience they've got no
sort of um way of doing something
they've just seen something on the
internet and they'll come back to us
and i want to buy a buy to let property
what do you own anything
well no not at the moment okay what's
your income oh i'm not really earning
anything and i don't know
have you got any deposit well not really
have you got anybody else that can come
in with you not really
so there's a lot of now you've got that
message out there that you can generally
make
money at a property unfortunately
there's a lot of people that are saying
well skip samuels or anyone else's
training
let me go direct to the brokers and i
can probably get the deal you know what
it's another thing i'm really really
passionate about
look if you're going to be a
professional anything if you're going to
be a professional
golfer hairdresser doctor lawyer sister
anything
you need to go through professional
training and if you don't
you're going to get blown flat and
property is the most
arguably the most lucrative profession
on the planet
and if you want to make it as a property
investor or a property entrepreneur
you need to get training now i'm not
saying you need to spend tens of
thousands of pounds on training but you
need to at least put dedicate some time
to to learning your craft before you
just start blindly
having a bash if you have a bash you're
going to have a crash um
you know so i think it's really
important for people to speak to brokers
and accountants and solicitors and
get professional advice i just think
it's it's um it's really important
to spend a little bit of time actually
thinking about
what your goals are how property is
going to be able to serve you and help
you in your in your business and what
your plan is what you you know do your
market research figure out the supply
and demand
work out what your strategy is
understand what different strategies are
available to you
you know come to my if you come to my
free event yes i'm going to sell and i'm
going to sell it
come on every every everyone knows you
know
nothing in this world unfortunately is
fully free you've got you've got
google google is not fully free you are
the information
okay you are the product with google
with youtube
you are the product okay so nothing is
free there is always a product at the
end of it now
whatever that product is however that's
positioned to you that's that's a
different argument but
you know if you're going to put your
time and you're going to go with
everything so
for me if i'm doing the videos i i'm
doing youtube videos
okay youtube videos why am i doing it
well i'm doing it ultimately to give the
information out
and out of say 20 000 people that view
it a month
some of them will say actually this
guy's a nice guy next time i get a
mortgage i want to deal with him yeah
okay
that's what i'm doing so that's why i'm
trying to that's why i'm putting the
video out there
at the end of the day i'm you know i
want to get the information out there
um it's i think it's useful however at
the end of the day
my underlining tone is give me a call
yeah you know what though it'll be like
getting annoyed with someone
for giving you a little bit of pizza
when you walk past
the pizza shop oh would you like a bit
of pizza and then you go oh thank you
and you eat and then you go
hang on a minute you're just trying to
give me a taste to get me to go any
pizza it's like
exactly and i think
most people will accept we will accept
that you know uh with with anything we
do
um you know we're trying we're trying to
grow a business we're trying to live our
lives we're trying to share
information that we've we've gained at
the end of the day
so the information you know for example
um
the next person the next person that
wants to buy a
castle okay and and picks the phone up
to you and say samuel i'm thinking of
buying a castle
you'd probably be able to give them a
lot of information about some of the
things that you
personally didn't know about or learned
over that yeah exactly
yeah i've seen videos i mean i've seen
you you've promoted other
mortgage brokers or you sat down with uh
i think it was a young chap you sat down
with i've seen that you
sit down with bridging experts and
various many many brokers because i
think
you know what the whole way i live my
life and run my business is very much
hands open kind of i'm very hands open
i'm not
um you know closed off also this is this
is you know i've got
i've i have other property trainers on
my channel and i'll
chat with them and share and my youtube
channel is all about adding value to the
audience it's not
it's i don't just see it as a as like a
marketing funnel it's
it's just to give value and to you know
provide content for people and i know
that if i keep doing that
um you know you you'll report your so
so i'll be very happy to do you know to
do stuff with you for instance i
wouldn't be thinking just because
i've got a mortgage firm um that i've
got a joint venture in
i'm closed off to promoting or
giving any exposure for everybody at the
end of the day it's plenty of business
for everybody
you're we're more than welcome to ever
come around for a coffee mate it's just
around the corner you are literally
around the corner from us so
i'm happy to meet you whenever whenever
you got some time i know you're a busy
man but
you know it's always good to have a chat
and and just see what other other people
are doing and how you're getting on
yeah no i appreciate it well yeah i'm
sure we could you know i'm sure we could
benefit
you know each other's businesses and
stuff um i'd be very very happy to do
stuff
um you know a lot and again for me by
the way just for the record and i know
i've got quite a big
in in terms of our niche because we've
got a very niche
um kind of kind of topic uh investment
channels
and i know i've got quite a big center
but on a personal level
i'm never concerned about numbers and
stuff like i'm really not concerned
about
numbers i'm more concerned just about
who i'm who i'm collabing with
what value they bring you know what
their knowledge and their
um values you know that's the kind of
thing i've collabed with people that
have got
a hundred subscribers and i've collabed
with people that have
got millions of subscribers yeah you
know i'm not really no
i really appreciate that that's what it
is you know whether we use any of this
content stuff whether we deal with we
don't it doesn't really matter
i just thought i started off as someone
that watched you and i was very
dubious i have to say right i'm not sure
about this guy i'm not sure i'm not sure
is is he just the charlotte is he just
and then i was reading some other videos
i watched other people
before i actually got to watch your
videos i was watching other videos and
there was a lot of
say in the last year year and a half
there's a lot of bad blood between
so i thought well you carried on i mean
i carried on watching a lot of your
stuff
and then i thought well do you know what
this guy's actually you know he's trying
to do his thing
you know at the end of the day he's
getting attacked for whatever but he's
trying to do his thing is his thing
useful to others
at the end of the day pull everything
else aside put the politics aside put
everything
is it useful to the average joe and i
thought yeah it is
of course it is and and can i can i
is he someone that i like to talk to and
get his opinion from yes it was so
and that's what i wanted to do really
and and i'm i'm really pleased we had
this chat because uh
you've come across as a you know as what
you are on that videos
so and it's someone that you know i'm
glad to say that i know now
oh thanks pam well i appreciate that i
know it's by the way you've started
moving towards facebook and youtube
because i saw that you were worried
about them taking something of your
videos down or something
yeah yeah yeah they kept removing stuff
they kept taking down videos
i did an interview with grant cardone i
interviewed my dad to be fair my dad's
interview was a little bit um i can
um yeah he why would they take i don't
want to take too much of your time i
know you've got kids and stuff
why would they why would they take your
stuff down so it was when we were
talking about the the pandemic and the
potential government agenda behind it
and they just did not take kindly to
that
i just ripped it from youtube threatened
to
permanently delete my channel that's a
big platform for you that's a big part
of your business if
for youtube sort of tomorrow says see
you later
oh i'm not bothered i'm not really that
bold if if youtube
remove my channel i just set up another
channel and people will come and follow
my audience know who i am they know
where i'm at so i'm not really that
bothered to be honest you know what let
me just keep talking about what i know
which is property investment and how to
make money and how to deal with people
and
so um yeah but it was a bit of a it's
it's not good that they're silencing
people and not letting people have a
voice on these topics but
it is what it is yeah no absolutely mate
listen uh
yeah well that sounds i hope i don't get
one of those strikes
that's what i would say but um listen
thank you so much sam i really really
appreciate you taking the time it's been
really really good
thanks and and hopefully i'll get when
all this dies down a little bit
you're only around the corner whether we
meet at yours whether we meet our minor
whether we meet somewhere in the middle
yeah it'd be really good
i don't know if you i don't know if your
personal trainer will
will allow you to have a point yeah for
sure
yeah that'd be great hey thanks pam
great to meet you i appreciate your time
and uh
all the best of your channel keep up the
great work support so much really
appreciate